[Music]
when I was younger I definitely think I
had a sex addiction some kind if you
won't have a lot of sex that's great
well why are you having all that sex
that's what you gotta lick candid
revelations from Jada who says she
battled several addictions throughout
her life including alcohol I remember
reaching a rock bottom and I had those
two bottles of wine and was going for
the third bottle it was like now hold up
you in this house by yourself going on
to your third bottle of wine join you
Jada for her Facebook watch series read
Table Talk her sister-in-law Ashley
Marie an R&B singer August Alsina both
who have struggled with addiction and
when I visited the set Jada told me why
she's putting it all out there are
people really prepared they believe they
know Jada I don't know if people are
ready but I know I am I'm hoping that it
will give people the freedom also in
their lives to find their truth during
this week's episode Jada's mom Adrien
also opened up about kicking a heroin
addiction 27 years ago surrender yeah so
that I could see what are you sometimes
it's hard for me to even really talk
about our journey together and I'm
always so freakin grateful because we
made it
[Music]